mear is this country that used to be cut
off from the world but in 2012 they
started opening up and they got
connected to the internet Facebook
launched in the country very quickly and
made a deal with cell phone companies
that any phone would come preluded with
Facebook and that users could have
unlimited data if they used Facebook it
spread like wildfire and soon the
platform became inundated with hate
speech against the Muslim minority the
rohinga Facebook only had one moderator
to try to handle all of this and the
platform was completely overrun
eventually the military itself started
using Facebook to at anti- rohinga
propaganda and it all culminated with
what the UN called a textbook case of
ethnic cleansing when the military and
burmes citizens drove the rohinga out of
the country this violence wasn't caused
by Facebook but Facebook was a key tool
for spreading this hate and causing this
genocide if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more